let's get to calls and see what's on
people's minds we will first go at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 52 our caller from the 204 area
code caller from 204 tell us who you are
where you're calling from and what's on
your mind today
hi you are on yes and if we're on
speaker or Bluetooth please do take us
off yeah I'm aware so my name is Thomas
I'm actually from Manitoba Canada and I
watched your show for a while and and I
agree with I appreciate your your
academic kind of outlook on some complex
issues thank you the question for you
today is this and I'm not sure how to
phrase this so some some patience but
I've noticed and I've been kind of
disturbed that the media has been tested
portraying george w bush in a better
light that donald trump no I'm a
university student willing to your
college and based on my studies and
based on what academia to say
objectively speaking it is a dangerous
potentially dangerous idea to portray
where it is by some UN definitions a war
criminal a man that not only exploded
you demand and Americans domestically
but effectively crew was one could even
argue was the reason Isis exists today
Donald Trump's make things he is a big
agent among other things that a business
man but do you think that it's on that
it's potentially what's concerning that
the media know that you haven't but I've
noticed that many other talk show I was
have done this yes you know you're
bringing up an absolutely important
point which is we often in order to show
how ridiculous Donald Trump is in his
behavior we'll find ourselves saying
even george w bush didn't do this and
the danger of that can be that we are
starting to think of george w bush but
sort of looking at george w bush bush
through rose-colored glasses and I think
that is dangerous and that's why I try
to make a point every time Thomas when I
say this I say even george w
Bush who was a disastrous president
crushed the economy started the Iraq war
on completely false pretenses it was a
total neoliberal war hawk even he who I
disagree with so vehemently would never
have stoop to this level so I always try
to couch it to make sure that I'm not
saying Bush wasn't that bad
I'm saying it's amazing that even
someone as bad as Bush wouldn't have
thought of doing this thing that Trump
did so I agree with you completely and I
think we've got a we've got to talk
about that responsibly if we want to
make a comparison to george w bush drive
a minute longer just a quick little
follow-up yes I mean so I know this is
maybe more and this is this is from an
outside perspective so I I do not mean
to disrespect anyone elses listening to
this right but but from based on my know
I'm very liberal minded obviously I but
basically my concern though is that who
do you think and I know this is a bit of
a better point but that almost American
egoism like this I couldn't pull this
and cap liked this idea of that that
that a lot of the issues that people are
criticizing shrimp for have existed
since antiquity and I and I believe and
they're been arguments and in my
university that this is the result of
this idea that America is the greatest
nation in the world that you're the
leader piece and objectively speaking if
we look through what academia has
disabled the topics these are simply
falsehoods and I and I almost wonder
like like saying can deference is we
don't perpetuate this idea that Canada
is the greatest nation in the world we
are one of the great nations the world
but not thee do you understand like we
don't have any equivalent to a Canadian
Tareen
we have you know do you know what I mean
and I I do I'm not sure I understand
that where you're going but I do
understand that it's being a confident
and I do have to I've got to move on I
really appreciate the call though I that
last part I think we went maybe went a
bit off but but I do really appreciate
the call